[Applause]
another day in a newsroom in a slum
event but ab tak TV is testament to the
pandemic the world is going through
right now while these journalists
sanitize and wear masks many others in
Pakistan complain they don't have
protective equipment when they go out to
report at least 12 journalists have
tested positive for coronavirus this
woman but cuz we have many media workers
have been infected with the corona virus
while working in the field without any
safety measures the media company is
employing them are responsible for that
by forcing their journalists to work in
this way and if they refuse they have
been fired from their jobs nearly 40,000
journalists work for more than 80 news
outlets in Pakistan a job that already
comes with high risks and they are now
faced with a new threat we journalists
are on the main line as well we are
working from the very first day and we
are providing the right information to
the people at the time and we are
vulnerable as well but no help from the
government side Rawalpindi Islamabad
Union if journalists took matters into
its own hands distributing community
made masks and gowns the Pakistani
government is the sole provider of
personal safety equipment and it says it
will soon starts providing it to
journalists nationwide infighting
coronavirus I think health care staff
were more vulnerable than journalists so
as a priority we provided medical staff
with protective equipment but now in the
next phase the journalism community will
also be provided with these kits so they
can continue their work safely
journalists in Pakistan had already been
protesting against pay cuts and layoffs
well before the pandemic started the
situation has since gone from bad to
worse union leaders say at least 70% of
journalists haven't received their
salaries for up to 6 months last year
the Committee to Protect Journalists
reported increased media censorship in
Pakistan of the 25 journalists killed in
2019 3
from there and with a global pandemic
journalists need protection now more
than ever
so to hide at Al Jazeera